[Música]
bueno
voy a comenzar haciendo es una pregunta
porque comemos carne la comemos en todo
momento de muchas maneras diferentes de
hecho para muchos es la máxima
experiencia culinaria el ser humano como
especie omnívora que es obtienen sus
nutrientes de muchas fuentes y una de
ellas es de la carne en una dieta
saludable y equilibrada se recomienda
que el 35 por ciento de las calorías
ingeridas sea en forma de proteína esta
proteína tiene unos componentes básicos
que se llaman aminoácidos que nos ayudan
a regular muchos de los aspectos que
tiene nuestro cuerpo ayuda a construir y
regenerar tejidos y ayuda a sintetizar
hormonas que nos ayudan en el
metabolismo como la insulina por ejemplo
ahora vamos a hablar de números según la
onu somos 7 mil 300 millones de personas
en el mundo y en media cada una de esas
personas come 76 gramos de proteína al
día si hacemos las cuentas esto sabe que
tenemos que producir 202 mil millones de
toneladas de carne al año y estamos
hablando de hoy que si nos vamos al 2050
hablamos de números de 9.700 millones de
personas y en el 2100 seremos 11 mil 200
millones de personas el ser humano un
ser inteligente creó un modelo para
poder abastecer a todo el planeta el
modelo de la ganadería intensiva nos ha
estado alimentando durante mucho tiempo
pero seguimos creciendo seguimos
demandando comer comer carne y este
sistema ha llegado a los límites y están
en una situación de sobreexplotación y
eso lo estamos viendo en nuestro día a
día en diferentes ámbitos estamos
expuestos a riesgos sanitarios
exposición a pandemias gripe aviar
fiebre porcina vacas locas
tenemos riesgos para la salud el 80 por
ciento de los antibióticos que se
producen en el mundo no son para consumo
humano son para consumo de ganado esos
antibióticos
posteriormente se quedan en la carne que
ingerimos sin ningún tipo de control y
además creamos resistencia a ellos con
lo cual uno de los mayores inventos y
descubrimientos de la medicina no se
está quedando con poca eficacia además
hay una dosis de hormonas que estamos
ingiriendo poco controlada y también
tenemos acceso a carnes con un gran
contenido en grasa que afecta a nuestras
enfermedades cardiovasculares no nos
podemos olvidar de cuestiones éticas
estamos preocupados hoy en día la
sociedad por el bienestar animal está
sobre explotación hay mucho sacrificio y
sufrimiento animal que ya está en tela
de juicio además es una de las primeras
causas de emisión de gases de efecto
invernadero tiene el 14 5 por ciento de
la cuota global es superior a la cuota
del transporte con aviones y barcos
incluidos
y además es la primera causa de
deforestación del planeta porque en
media cada animal para hacer un
kilogramo de carne tiene que consumir 6
kilogramos de pienso lo que quiere decir
es que hay que hacer mucho pienso y
todos esos campos que vemos cuando vamos
por las carreteras muchos son para
pienso animal no son para piensos de
consumo humano si además de esto le
añadimos la contaminación de acuíferos y
de suelos que se produce alrededor de
las granjas de ganadería intensiva
tenemos un problema grande y a nivel
global
muchos innovadores de la alimentación
están intentando poner soluciones y
poner alternativas y por ejemplo una de
ellas es cómo están cambiando las
hamburguesas vegetales en un inicio
cuando las hemos visto durante bastante
tiempo en los supermercados más
orientados y a lo mejor a un público
vegetariano o vegano porque a los
carnívoros no les apetecía mucho
probarlas pero hoy en día tenemos nuevas
opciones
esto es para atraer a un público
carnívoro para intentar reducir el
consumo de carne animal el problema es
que la proteína animal y la proteína
vegetal
son iguales hay una algo que se mide en
que es la cantidad neta útil de proteína
que nosotros podemos absorber y utilizar
y el cuerpo humano el sistema digestivo
está preparado para metabolizar
proteínas animales pero la proteína
vegetal le cuesta un poco con lo cual no
podemos solo sustentar toda esta demanda
adicional que va a haber con proteínas
vegetales en 1.931 winston churchill
como buen visionario ya predijo que el
ser humano iba a escapar del absurdo de
crear un pollo entero si sólo queríamos
comernos la pechuga o el ala y 88 años
más tarde eso ha llegado viene de la
mano de la ingeniería de tejidos para
quien no esté familiarizado con este
término es una rama de la medicina
regenerativa y lo que trata es de hacer
construcciones funcionales para reparar
tejidos corporales u órganos algún
ejemplo de esto que seguro que habéis
visto en algún lugar son los injertos de
piel cartílago injertos de tráquea si
esto ha existido durante mucho tiempo
pero sólo hoy tenemos las herramientas
suficientes para poder pensar en crear
tejidos musculares que es la carne en
grandes cantidades y elaborar los en
forma de productos alimenticios cómo
funciona la técnica imaginaros un animal
vamos a visualizar un animal en
perfectas condiciones cuanto mejor esté
es mejor la muestra que vamos a sacar
una vaca un pollo un cerdo les traemos
una muestra de carne por ejemplo de una
pata esta muestra de carne sabemos que
tejido muscular tiene venas tiene grasa
tiene nervios bueno pues hay técnicas
muy conocidas en medicina que te
permiten aislar las células que tú
quieres de esos tejidos como a nosotros
nos interesa la proteína porque queremos
dar una buena cantidad nutritiva de ella
pues vamos a aislar las células
musculares esto se hace en un periodo
muy corto de tiempo con lo cual esos
tejidos siguen vivos
esos tejidos los puedes colocar en un
ambiente controlado y favorecido para
ellas que lo único que quiere decir es
que les vamos a poner en un medio acoso
que tienen proteínas aminoácidos sales
minerales aire para vivir y ellas siguen
creciendo y haciendo su función y la
función de las células musculares es
hacer tejido muscular lleno de proteínas
de esta manera si después se colocan en
un tipo de fermentado oro biorreactor
que simula el cuerpo del animal puedes
obtener una masa muscular libre de
grasas si así lo deseamos sin necesidad
de haber matado ningún animal para que
os hagáis una idea de muestras sacadas
de un cerdo durante un año podemos tener
la misma capacidad productiva que de 400
cerdos teniendo una matanza
es una carne que respeta el bienestar
animal es una carne que como habéis
visto con los números reduce mucho el
consumo de recursos y además no tiene
ningún tipo de exposición a pandemias
los animales que utilizamos para sacar
las pruebas están en perfecto estado de
salud y a lo largo del proceso no tienen
ningún tipo de exposición ni a virus de
a bacterias bueno pues como está el
panorama global aquí tenemos unos
cuadrantes que nos explican cómo estamos
abajo tenemos la ganadería tradicional
está en los límites de sostenibilidad y
no puede seguir aumentando la producción
tenemos las alternativas que surgen para
ayudar a satisfacer toda esta demanda
las alternativas de origen vegetal
emulando esa carne para atraer y bajar
un poco el consumo y las alternativas
sostenibles de producción de proteína
animal por medio de carne de lo que se
llama la técnica de carne cultivada
como de reales esto en 2017 éramos cinco
empresas hoy en día somos 25 esto es
imparable ya es una realidad o se ha
marcado en rojo las que pertenecen a la
unión europea y no son los que estén
saliendo empresas que están produciendo
carne cultivada es que la industria
cárnica está apoyando a estas empresas
porque son conscientes de la falta de
recursos que tenemos para seguir
alimentando a la población del planeta
no sólo en la industria cárnica sino
todas las industrias asociadas a la
cadena de producción y distribución de
este tipo de productos y una cosa más
importante además no igual de importante
los gobiernos están apoyando esas
iniciativas y desde las autoridades
regulatorias están preparados para
regularlas en la unión europea la
autoridad que valida los alimentos que
comemos se llama la etsa y en 2015 en su
artículo 22 83 por si alguien tiene
curiosidad y pudiera verlo se describe
el uso de novel food un novel food es
toda aquella comida que no sea
utilizado frecuentemente desde en 1997
bueno pues en 2017 ya se aprobó la
categoría de novel food como uno de
ellos es alimentos provenientes de
cultivos celulares la unión europea está
disponible ya para regular este tipo de
alimentos estos son los primeros
alimentos que se han hecho podéis ver
diferentes modelos hay carne de pollo
hay carne de cerdo hay carne de vaca y
nos podemos imaginar cómo será la
fábrica de la carne cultivada si lo que
estamos acostumbrados a ver es esto que
es la ganadería intensiva esto es lo que
vamos a ver esto nos agarraron esto ya
existe en la industria de la
alimentación realmente todos los yogures
y los productos lácteos que comemos
vienen de fermentadores o biorreactores
como estos el vino se hace en
fermentadores así y la cerveza usando
sus levaduras viven en fermentadores
como estos
y a estas alturas de la película os
estaréis preguntando bueno sí pero qué
opina el consumidor final que somos
todos nosotros bueno pues nosotros
obviamente también nos lo preguntábamos
hicimos un estudio un estudio de
aceptación del consumidor a nivel
nacional se hicieron unas encuestas en
las ciudades más pobladas de españa y lo
que obtuvimos fue muy gratificante
porque estamos mucho más preparados de
lo que pensamos entre el siguen no
siempre ganan los créditos del sí y la
gente está dispuesta a consumir este
tipo de carne lo que tienen claro todos
los síes y los noes y sobre todo en un
80 por ciento de la población sabe que
en 5 años esta carne va a estar en los
lineales del supermercado y con toda
esta información podéis pensar lo que
queráis los consumidores de carne
podéis incluso engañar o seguir pensando
que vamos a comer carne como hemos hecho
hasta ahora de manera indefinida los
vegetarianos y veganos lo mismo podéis
tener una dieta más flexible o quizá no
por las razones por la que hayáis
escogido ese tipo de dieta lo que está
claro es que la pregunta que os echo al
principio de por qué comemos carne está
encima de la mesa y los problemas de
sostenibilidad no van a desaparecer ni
tampoco las necesidades que tenemos como
especie ésta es la carne menos
contaminante que se ha hecho en el mundo
la podéis llamar como queráis tiene
varios nombres carne cultivada carne in
vitro cream y en eeuu carne ética pero
lo que está claro es que va a llegar a
los lineales del supermercado lo vais a
tener disponible o un familiar o un
amigo os la va a poner encima de la mesa
y entonces vais a tener la capacidad y
la posibilidad de elegir muchas gracias
[Aplausos]